the bagel is one of new york city's most
iconic foods and the all-new bodega
bagel is bringing the taste of new york
bagels to henderson jc is live at their
grand opening hey jc
hey mercedes hey jillian we are super
excited because henderson has a new
bagel joint this is sonia the owner
congratulations thank you so much so how
did this whole concept come about
because you were originally downtown
first yeah so we did this during the
pandemic at the downtown vegas kitchen
and then
i had a great turnout so i decided why
not do a brick and mortar which was
always my intention and then i came upon
this space i partnered up with
love group and here we are here we are
today was day number one how day number
how would you describe the vibe of the
place it's a great feeling i think it
had a really good hustle and bustle it
felt good it was fresh uh there were
lots of people lots of regulars from
rooster boys showed up it was really
nice a lot of friends from the community
i i think we're definitely a bit
overwhelmed but you know it's the first
day it's got to work out on a lot of
things but let's have a seat at our
table we have a table set up because
it's a new york style uh bagels and
you're from new york city so that's the
tie in there what are some of the uh the
items that people should try on the menu
i would definitely recommend the
platters the lower east side the upper
east side i definitely think that our uh
hudson river is one of our favorites
look at this what so which one is in
front of me this is not just your
typical bagel what do you got here we
got everything bagel and it's called the
decker special we have a homemade
gravlox a cucumber dill with sour cream
salad and it's named after decker
chris decker the pizza man he used to
come downtown and have it and i called
it a cr chris decker i mean a decorative
special after him okay i'm going to take
a bite of this what what are some bagel
restaurants that inspired you growing up
uh i used to love to go to russ and
daughters i used to love to go to
jonah's canisius oh my god are you happy
right now oh my god
so i'm so happy this is fantastic thank
you so much i saw you guys had soups as
well we do we do matzo ball soup we do
borscht and we do a mushroom barley okay
as well as um
that's what those are so you can have it
as a cup a bowl or a court to take home
thank you you guys are open seven to
three right now
monday's closed and we do um
that's it one two three someone told me
about your cucumber salad you're just
here in henderson but someone told me
this cucumber salad is world famous
really yes it's already that's the word
on the streets when i try the cucumber
salad give this a whirl right here it's
very fresh and i think it's really nice
when you have smoked fish to have
cucumber and the dill is really
refreshing wow that is so refreshing
especially on a hot day like this i know
pastries as well so we have a blueberry
corn muffin and a cheese danish i really
want to toast the blueberry muffin like
in new york you know when they cut it
and they put it on the flat top with
butter i love it but we'll we'll do that
a little later i got to wrap it up
location where are we located uh 175
south uh
eastern state road this busy busy
opening day eastern and saint rose it
was a pop quiz you're looking at eastern
state roads
uh bodega bagel is now open las vegas
now we will be right back
[Music]
furniture